Ah, jetzt haben wir Qualitätsoptionen, jetzt haben wir Qualitätsoptionen.
Ich finde das lustig, dass man durch einfach 1-2 mal an- und ausschalten, dass man Qualitätsoptionen
kriegt, tja, Twitch-Logik in 2k18, null, nice, ja Qualitätsoptionen ist wichtig,
weil wir sind in Deutschland und in Deutschland kann halt leider nicht jeder 8 MBit gucken.
So, ich bin gleich da, ich muss jetzt nämlich noch mal, ich muss noch mal was zu trinken
holen, dann muss ich Twitter posten, ich mach halt mal Youtube-Post, mal gucken, ob da noch
mehr kommen, mal gespannt, easy clap, easy cuts FPS, EZF, EZF, EZF, EZF, EZF, EZF, EZF,
so, ich bin gleich wieder da, trinken holen, mach ein paar Posts, dann gehts los, ich häng
fest, ich häng fest, Edzak hier weg, jetzt doch Dark Messiah, ja, ich finde meine Bad
Company 1 DVD nicht, ich bin gleich wieder da.
So, ich bin gleich wieder da, trinken holen, mach ein paar Posts, dann gehts los, ich häng
fest, ich häng fest, ich häng fest, ich bin gleich wieder da, trinken holen, mach ein
paar Posts, dann gehts los, ich häng fest, ich häng fest, ich bin gleich wieder da,
trinken holen, mach ein paar Posts, dann gehts los, ich häng fest, ich häng fest, ich
bin gleich wieder da, trinken holen, mach ein paar Posts, dann gehts los, ich häng fest,
ich bin gleich wieder da, trinken holen, mach ein paar Posts, dann gehts los, ich häng
fest, ich bin gleich wieder da, trinken holen, mach ein paar Posts, dann gehts los, ich häng
fest, ich bin gleich wieder da, trinken holen, mach ein paar Posts, dann gehts los, ich
bin gleich wieder da, trinken holen, mach ein paar Posts, dann gehts los, ich bin gleich
So, jetzt bin ich am start, ähm, hach weg hier, ist noch irgendwie ne Mist eingeblendet,
ahja den denkst du. So, mir fällt grad was ein, ich hab in meinem Vorschau Browser gar keine
Bella-Twinch-TV-Emotes, das ist ganz schöner Rotz, ne, das geht ja gar nicht, das sieht man ja nix, da seh ich kein Coggers, ja, kein Poggers,
kein Monk, äh, gar nix, ja, also die wichtigsten Emotes seh ich gar nicht, vor allem auch keinen hier, das ist ja ganz schlimm.
Das wollt ich gleich mal nachholen, wobei ich mir Frank Your Faces Z installiere, weil, find ich besser.
Irgendwie gehts euch auch so, dass ihr in den Menüs von Webbrowsern überhaupt nix mehr findet, ich muss immer ewig suchen, bis ich auf die Addon-Page komme,
nein, das ist jetzt unser Chrome, muss man sich mal vorstellen, das ist jetzt oben, also guck mal, ne, wenn ich Chrome-Addons aufmachen will, da muss man auf diese komischen Punkte, da muss man auf More Tools, da muss man auf Extensions, das, wenn man das nicht oft macht, findet es doch keine Sau.
So, und jetzt mal kurz nachladen, die Seite, jetzt sollte ich eigentlich wieder mal testen, jetzt sollte ich, ja, jetzt sollte ich wieder Emotes sehen, sehr schön, gut, jetzt brauchen wir bloß noch ein Twitter-Post, und dann gehts los.
Porgans, beste, Porgans sind schnell, also beste Emotes ein und immer noch 0.4D, da haben wir uns selbst übertroffen im Streben hier, dass wir das überhaupt kreiert haben, ich mein normales 0.3D ist schon geil, 0.4D top, das ist wirklich alles.
Spielst du noch Overwatch? Ne, Overwatch ranked ist so anstrengend und so Tilt und Rage anfällig, das halt ich nicht aus.
So, jetzt muss ich mir mal irgendwie, ich brauch mal eine gute YouTube-Community-Message, was ich da posten kann.
So, Twitter-Post.
Was für eine Tastatur benutzt du? Ich müsste echt mal jetzt langsam mal von Corsare Geld verlangen.
Die hier, hier da, guck, da, wobei ich, wobei ich E2 gekauft hab und die andere find ich eigentlich besser, die hab ich auf der Arbeit rein vom Tippgefühl her, also zum Game ist die hier, zum Spielen ist die hier gut,
aber rein, also zum tippen, so wenn man überwiegend tippt und auch spielt, dann würd ich mir die hier nochmal holen, die hab ich mir eine bestellt, die hab ich auf der Arbeit mit, aber mit Numpad, sieht man jetzt hier nicht da, die ist sehr nice, da fühlt sich auch die Knöppe irgendwie besser an.
Moin Eiskäuter, hast du schon gehört, was, hast du schon gehört, dass der normale MP in Black Ops 4.0 in 2.0 ein Scherz läuft, obwohl die Beta in 6.0 ein Scherz lief, das hab ich schon gehört, ich weiß allerdings nicht so genau warum, außer wenn man, dass man die Spieler irgendwie verarschen will, ich weiß nicht, keine Ahnung.
So lacht der Motto krasse Beta und dann zackts, Balls alter zackts, 20 Herz, das ist 1998, also jetzt brauch ich mal ne ordentliche YouTube Community Message, die ich posten kann, was verschreibe man da?
So, das war's für heute, bis zum nächsten Mal, bis zum nächsten Mal, bis zum nächsten Mal, bis zum nächsten Mal, bis zum nächsten Mal.
Das war's für heute, bis zum nächsten Mal, bis zum nächsten Mal, bis zum nächsten Mal, bis zum nächsten Mal.
So, jetzt haben wir auch noch einen YouTube-Post.
Und dann geht's los. Hat das Spiel jemand schon gespielt? Kennt das jemand von euch?
Das ist auch schon ein bisschen älter, das kam 2008 oder so. Ich weiß noch, ich war auf der
Gamescom, als sie das vorgestellt haben. Auf der Gamesconvention hieß das ja noch, ja 2008.
Da war ich mit dem Friseur zusammen in Leipzig damals noch auf der Gamesconvention. Da haben wir
das sogar mal getestet. Also angespielt, noch bevor es rauskommt. Jetzt sieht man, wie ewig
der Scheiß von den ersten zehn Jahren.
Kann man in YouTube Community Messages irgendwas verlinken? Irgendwie funktionieren die Links nicht.
Komisch. Läuft auf Source Engine, ja. Macht es.
So. Post wird das mal auf YouTube. Bäm. Vielleicht gibt's jetzt gleich Instant Strike von YouTube,
weil die nicht wollen, dass man auf Twitch aufmerksam macht. Also das Game sah im Vergleich zu
4. Letzten Stream haben wir 4 gespielt. Das Spiel sah für 2005 extrem geil aus. Dark Messiah of
Might and Magic sah jetzt nicht so geil aus, als es rausgekommen ist. Wann kam Crysis 1 raus?
Wo die auf YouTube Probleme damit haben, ist, wenn man quasi ein Video hochlädt, nur um
zu sagen, man ist live. Das kann man ja auch irgendwo nachvollziehen. Das kam im gleichen
Jahr raus wie Crysis und dafür sieht es echt nicht sonderlich gut aus. Aber das hat das
niceste Ego-Miele-Nachkampf-Stellsystem, was ich so kenne. Das ist echt geil. So. Legen
wir mal los. Wie gesagt, ich muss heute spätestens 22 Stunden ins Bett, aber das sind ja noch
4,5 Stunden. Das ist noch ein bisschen hin. Das machen wir wieder auf die Arbeit, auch
wenn ich keinen Bock hab. Da kommen wir nicht drum herum. Okay, auf geht's. Tastatur haben
wir durch, Musik machen wir mal aus. Das Game hat einen ganz coolen Soundtrack. Ich werde
jetzt mal das Intro laufen lassen und ihr müsst mir mal wieder sagen, ob der Sound stimmt,
weil wir sind ja auf Twitch und da ist das Sound und die Qualitätssettings jedes Mal
anders. Wie kann ich programmieren? Ja, kann ja nicht immer. Vor allem, ich habe da gerade
so ein paar Schwierigkeiten, wo ich nicht genau weiß, wie ich es machen soll. Deswegen
muss ich mir erstmal off-stream ein paar Gedanken zu machen. MIG Muted, ja, ist klar. Mein MIG
ist nicht Muted. Meinst du, ich seh das nicht, oder? Gebaited. Hardcore Gebaited. So, ich
lass jetzt mal das Intro laufen und dann müssen wir mal gucken, wie der Sound ist. Voller Lautstärke
haben. Also, schießt mal los, klar. Play. Game. Äh, Moment. Eigentlich sollte da jetzt
ein Intro laufen. Eigentlich sollte da jetzt ein Intro laufen. Das Game hat aber irgendwie
keinen Bock gehabt. Ja, Quit. Game. Hallo? Äh, okay, ähm. What the fuck? Was denn jetzt
schon wieder? Okay, äh, jetzt muss ich erstmal das Game wieder abschießen. Auch gut. Man
weiß ja nicht so genau, was wieder da kaputt ist. Das ist richtig MonkaS. So, jetzt noch
mal. Ah, altes Ubisoft. Ja, ach, ich glaub, die Lautstärke passt so ganz gut. Oh. Ja,
okay. Na, dann. Lautstärke, okay. Reuen Sie, Varo. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay.
Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Reuen Sie, Varo.
Was ist das, ist das eine Lich King in Rot?
Das sieht so aus, oder?
Die letzte Tochter von einer verlassenen Linie wird ihn in die Geschichte führen.
Beneath the crypt, prophecies clash. The war of ancient enemies.
Ich muss mal kurz checken.
Wisst ihr, was mir bei alten Games mega auf den Keks geht?
Dass man dich raustappen kann.
Ganz werkwichtig, du kannst aus alten Games nicht raustappen.
Und wenn man es doch macht, dann hängt es.
Guckt euch mal an.
So, war die Lautstärke okay?
Wir wurden wieder umgestellt auf indische Tastatur.
Irgendwie haben manche Games da unter Windows 10 so ein paar Probleme.
Dass man ganz gerne umgestellt wird auf indische Tastatur, fragt mich nicht warum.
Wahrscheinlich ist es der indische Microsoft Support daran schuld.
Okay, auf geht's.
Wir spielen mal auf Normal.
Das Game ist auf Hard und Hardcore teilweise sehr schwer.
Es sei denn, man klitscht rum mit Bogen und hinter einer Ecke, wo die Gegner nicht rumkommen.
Aber es ist so ein Game, was auf Hard eher nervig wird als Hard.
Ja, Tutorial Level.
Ich finde das toll, wenn die Voice Actors immer alle so super bedeutungsvoll sprechen müssen.
Es ist jetzt nicht möglich in einem Fantasy Spiel normales Voice Over zu machen.
Das muss ich alles so episch anhören.
Ja, okay und Taschenlampe gibt es natürlich nicht.
Dafür hat man Mage Vision oder sowas.
Easy, durchgespielt.
Übrigens.
Übrigens, ich habe das Game relativ oft früher durchgespielt.
Bestimmt vier, fünf Mal.
Also, halt doch mal die Klappe.
Die Story ist nicht schlecht.
Das fängt ein bisschen blöd an.
Mein Gott, lass mich doch mal was erzählen.
Und vor allem kommen Dämonengrills drin vor.
Dämonengrills, die den Held verführen wollen.
Und eigentlich, ja ihr seht es ja dann.
Moment, ich fail gerade das Tutorial.
Auf, ich lerne gerade zu sprinten.
Wie lange streamst du schon? Fünf Minuten?
Sechs Dämonengrills.
Und kommt direkt nach dem Tutorial, die Dämonengrills.
Da seht ihr das gleich schon.
Source-Texturen.
Ja, und nachdem das ein Source-Game ist.
Underage, der Sebaro wieder.
Ne, wahrscheinlich eher so 800 Jahre alt.
Also, vollkommen in Ordnung.
So, und nachdem das ein Source-Game ist, hat man natürlich auch wieder so schöne Physik-Dinger.
Und das 360-Portenzial ist in dem Game auch sehr hoch.
Generell ist das das einzige Game seiner Art, was ich kenne.
Also, natürlich Skyrim hat auch Ego-Perspektive, Zauberstelle.
Ja, ich weiß.
Ist halt Tutorial.
Aber von der Dynamik her und mit diesem Physik-Krams und so, mir fällt kein anderes Game in der Richtung ein.
Ach, C ist ducken.
Kennt ihr?
Verwirrt euch das auch immer, wenn manche Games ducken auf C legen anstatt auf Steuerung.
Du drückst immer instinktiv Steuerung und dann passiert nichts.
Ultraschweres Rätsel.
Skyrim für Arme.
Ne, hat mit Skyrim eigentlich gar nichts zu tun.
Es ist deutlich gradliniger.
Dafür hat es eine rote Livie.
Und weil es halt so aus ist, gibt es halt schöne Physik-Stell-Dinger.
Achtung.
Schreckt.
Und jetzt?
Äh, komm jetzt hier nicht, einmal kommen noch mehr.
Man konnte irgendwie auch im Rennen, ne?
Ach ne, das hab ich bestimmt noch nicht freigeschaltet.
Schreckt.
Blut, das ist kein Skelett, das war ein Ghoul oder sowas.
Adi, adi, spam.
Da kann keiner was machen.
Achtung.
Der wird jetzt gereckt.
Bam.
Boah, habt ihr es gesehen, wie knapp der an den Stacheln vorbei ist?
Man sieht schon, das Game legt es auf Physik-Krams an.
Ich wollte ihn grad impalen, aber es hat nicht funktioniert.
Doch, jetzt.
Zack.
Das war nix.
Oh, noch so ein Typ.
Das Schwert ist viel zu kurz.
Wir probieren jetzt mal was.
Komm mal her.
Treppe, Treppe, Treppe.
Bam.
Tyrannosaurus schreckt.
Noch einer.
Zack.
Wie, der lebt noch?
Warte mal, der kriegt jetzt ne Kiste gegen den Kopf.
So, das wars aber.
Nur, um auf Nummer sicher zu gehen.
Nur eine Fleischwunde, ja.
Boah, Skill-Punk.
Yeah.
So, gleich was backen.
Ja Leute, wir müssen jetzt, aber richtig in your face, Möppi.
Wir müssen jetzt gleich am Anfang eine wichtige Entscheidung treffen.
Das ist auch ein großer Unterschied zur 360-Version, falls ihr das Game immer auf der 360 gespielt habt.
Auf der 360 gibt's fertige Klassen.
Und, also das Game hier kam ja zuerst auf den PC raus.
Und sie waren irgendwie der Meinung, dass man als Konsolenspieler nicht zumuten kann,
ne, eigenes, was zu skillen.
Deswegen gibt's auf der 360-Version vorgefertigte Skills, also vorgefertigte Klassen.
Und hier nicht.
Das heißt, hier können wir selbst backen.
Das heißt, die Frage ist, was wir machen.
Es gibt grundsätzlich, glaub ich, fünf verschiedene Sachen.
Es gibt einmal Schwertnachkampf, Zweihänder oder Schild.
Es gibt solche mit Stellsangriff von hinten.
Das gibt's dann hier.
Irgendwo hier war das.
Hier, Stells.
Auf Stufe 2 kann man quasi so Backstab.
Da muss man halt schleichen.
Dann gibt's Bogen.
Bogen ist eigentlich scheiße, aber Bogen ist OP, weil man sich oben hinstellen kann und Gegner kaputt schießen.
Das spielen wir schon mal nicht.
Magie, Kram.
Ja, das war's eigentlich im Großen und Ganzen.
Oder so eine Mischung.
Jetzt ist die Frage natürlich, was wir backen wollen.
Backen wir auf In Your Face-Gekloppe?
Backen wir auf Magie oder Backen wir auf Stells?
Man kann das ein bisschen kombinieren.
Wir backen...
Wir müssen auch nicht gleich backen.
Wir gucken mal, was lohnt sich dann.
Weiter sprinten brauchen wir auf jeden Fall.
Ohne weiter sprinten geht schon mal nix.
Weil das ist viel zu nervig, wenn du überhaupt nicht richtig rennen kannst.
Wir backen jetzt erstmal ordentlich sprinten.
Das ist eigentlich das Wichtigste erstmal.
Ich würde sagen, wir backen so ein Zwischending.
Wir backen ein bisschen Backstab.
Also wir backen glaube ich Dolch bis zum Backstab.
Dass man Gegner halt killen kann.
In Your Face plus Stells, genau.
Das Game, früher kann ich mich noch dran erinnern, neigte das Game nach dem Intro abzustürzen.
Ich hoffe, das ist nicht so.
So, jetzt kommt Demon Grills.
Source Texturen an der Wand.
Das Game ist nicht gecrashed, das ist gut.
Was? Alter, Game?
Du sollst die Zwischensequenz nicht überspringen.
Was soll denn das Scheiß?
Ich hab die Lautstärke angepasst, ich hab die Lautstärke angepasst.
Bam, Zwischensequenz überspringen.
Was ist da los?
Jaja, das kennen wir schon.
Das ist aber massiver MonkaS gewesen gerade.
So, aber richtig.
Speedrun Strats.
Okay, da müssen wir uns jetzt kurz mal die 20 Sekunden Geschwätze von Master Fenrig neu anhören.
Ich drücke jetzt nichts.
Ich drücke nichts.
Nicht abgestürzt.
Story Mode.
Das ist das Merkel-Dreieck.
Boi.
Ich kann dir sogar ein paar andere Dinge beibringen.
Was bittest du, mein Master?
Einer kann leichter reisen als zwei, Sare.
Bin ich zu...
Protektieren, dieses Junge?
Keine Sorge, das wird nicht ein bisschen schaden.
Übrigens, mein Name ist...
Sarath.
Wo die?
Wie gesagt, das kam im gleichen Jahr raus wie Crysis.
Für Daheim.
Ich halte mal die Klappe, bis das Intro vorbei ist.
Ist mehr oder weniger auf sich.
Ich hör, wie Crysis kann es optisch nicht mithalten für das gleiche Jahr.
Moin, Maximum-Taktik.
Ahjaja, die wurden ja...
Ahjaja, wie cute, Chat.
Krieg sie weg.
Deswegen hab ich schneller Sprinten genommen, ihr erinnert euch?
Wo geht's lang?
Zack, zack, zack. Treppe rauf.
Die sind einfach runtergegangen.
Wow.
Weg.
Ich kann nicht mehr kicken, ich hab keine Endung mehr.
Was genau bist du gerade rumgefallen?
What? What?
Was?
Hab ich die Wache gekickt?
Ich hab die Wache gekickt, oder?
Ich glaub...
Ich glaub, ich hab die Wache gekickt.
Alter, das ist jetzt nicht euer Ernst, oder?
Oh nee, ich hab auch noch...
Okay, ich glaub, ich muss noch mal laden.
Ich muss noch mal laden.
Ich hab die Wache gekickt, das hat das Spiel bestimmt mitgesaved.
Oh Gott, Game.
Zum Glück hat man...
Game.
Okay, ich mach nix.
Wache, du machst das selbst.
Ich helf dir nicht.
Mach das mal selbst.
So.
Hände hoch.
Ich mach nix.
Klopf dich selbst mit dem Viech.
Oh, gekickt.
Ich weiß nicht, dass du umgekippt bist.
Ich hab dich nicht gekickt.
Okay.
Jetzt geht's weiter.
Irgendjemand hat gefragt, ob das Game War später Not Safe For Work wird.
Das dauert noch ne ganze Weile.
Das kriegen wir wahrscheinlich heute nicht hin.
Wird's, aber zumindest so n bisschen.
Aber nicht...
Dacht ich wirklich.
Aber Not Safe For Work auf jeden Fall.
Aber das dauert bestimmt noch 5 Stunden oder so.
Jetzt darf ich auf die Wachen schießen.
Das ist jetzt vollkommen in Ordnung.
Einer nicht raus.
Nein.
Kann man zoomen?
Darf ich zoomen?
Oh, oh.
Oh nein, vorbei.
Steckt.
So.
Jetzt ins Auge.
Jawoll.
184 reicht ganz knapp.
Aber mal richtig in your face.
Massiv in your face.
Wobei in your eye sowas gibt's glaub ich nicht.
Das hat noch keiner gesagt bisher.
Ich kann mir das so richtig vorstellen, dass irgendwie im nächsten Gist so vor sagen sie
es nicht mehr in your face, sondern in your eye.
Und dann haben sie es in der deutschen Version dann wieder übersetzt mit in dein Auge.
Genauso wie sie es jetzt auch übersetzt haben in Gist.
In Halo war das.
Wo sie dann die deutschen Sprecher sagen lassen haben.
Ja in dein Gesicht oder war das doch Gist so vor?
Ich weiß es nicht mehr.
Eine Foodration?
Sollte ich nicht ne Waffe haben?
Ich sollte ne Waffe haben oder?
Oder nicht?
Sollte ich nicht ne Waffe haben?
Moment.
Ich bilde mir ein ich sollte ne Waffe.
Ne anscheinend noch nicht.
Ok.
Dann müssen wir die Kiste leider kaputt treten.
Move dich Wache.
Als Potion.
Nichts drin.
So und danach müssen wir uns unbedingt überlegen was wir specken.
Das Ray Tracing ist der Wahnsinn.
Das Spiel sah für seine Zeit gar nicht so schlecht aus.
Ich mein Source Engine Games 2008 waren jetzt nicht absolut der Gipfel oder so.
Aber schon ganz ok.
Was haben wir denn hier?
Staff.
Also Stabkampf in dem Game das weiß ich von früher noch ist der letzte Kack.
Sack total.
Oh ein Bow.
Bow beste.
Haben wir Pfeile?
Reißpfeile sehr schön.
Haben wir vielleicht noch ein Schwert oder so für mich?
Was ordentlich ist.
Und danach müssen wir uns überlegen was wir specken.
Schild.
Daggers.
Nice.
Es sieht doch keiner dass da ein Schwert liegt.
Schwert.
Was ist Inventar?
Inf.
Ah hier Tab.
Sollen wir umsortieren den komischen Stab den braucht kein Mensch.
Die können wir gleich wieder kicken.
Bogen da.
Health Potion machen wir irgendwo hier hinten hin.
Schild hier.
Dark Vision brauch ich eh kaum aber da hin.
Gut.
So passt.
Safe.
Ich glaube ich specke jetzt mal das erste das ich ein Schild nehmen kann.
Weil einfach nur Schwert ist ziemlich doof.
Aber wir können auch Daggerstellen machen geht auch.
So was sind meine Objectives?
Entrance zum Haus vom Obermage finden.
Ich mach nix ich mach nix alles gut.
Alles gut ich mach nix.
Ganz ruhig.
Das ist auch in.
RPG ist aber geil.
Dass man in alle Häuser reinrennen kann und kein Juk zu wirklich.
Lea auch am Start.
Ich mag das Demon Grill.
Ach ja übrigens.
Es bleibt nicht nur beim Demon Grill.
Diese Zauberin die ihr da gerade gesehen habt.
Ich muss mal gucken ob es hier irgendwas zu looten gibt.
Wie gesagt ich kenne die Story ja schon.
Ich kann mich zwar nicht mal so richtig dran erinnern aber so grob.
Die Zauberin ist auch scharf auf den Held.
Wie der eben gestanden hat.
Das heißt man muss sich irgendwann im Laufe des Games entscheiden.
Ob man Demon Grill oder Zauberin haben will.
Was geht?
Gibt es hier irgendwie?
Alles gut.
Ich mach noch ein paar Sachen kaputt.
Ja ja ist gut.
Ich will nicht dass die Wachen sauer werden.
Weil ist das Game instant lose.
Instant verloren.
Wo ging es raus?
Da ging es raus.
Gucken ob es in einem Haus irgendwas zu looten gibt.
Hier waren wir schon.
Gucken wir mal ob wir noch hier irgendwie.
Und hier noch irgendwo rein kann.
Weil ein paar Health Potions sind schon nicht verkehrt.
Wieso denn entscheiden?
Weil die Story das so möchte.
So viel kann ich sagen.
Was genau ist blöd weil das ist Major Plot Point.
Mana Drank.
Scroll of Freeze.
Alles overrated Magic Crams.
Hier unten waren wir schon.
Gehen wir raus.
Das war anstrengend.
Hier ist der Keller.
Alles gut.
Ich war es.
Gehen wir weiter.
Hier waren wir schon.
Okay gehen wir zur Quest.
Gehen wir zur Main Quest.
Oh da oben ist was.
Seht ihr es?
Da.
Da ist was.
Das was leuchtet sind immer irgendwelche Tunic Items oder Special Items.
Kommt man da irgendwie rein?
Dann gehen wir auch gleich zur Main Quest.
Hier kommt man auch nicht rein.
Nope.
Keine Chance.
Rare Loot.
Ja es geht so.
Es ist kein Diablo mit dem Loot her aber es gibt im Endeffekt für jede Klasse ein paar
Ressorten und ein paar Ruben und ein paar Stellstinger und Zeug.
Okay.
Der Rock ist unglücklich geschnitten.
Was soll das sein?
Das ist ja ein Source Engine Gesichter.
Das konnten sie damals schon ganz gut.
Ich meine der Rock ist schon sehr unglücklich irgendwie.
Richtig.
Der Stream ist 48.
Okay.
Irgendwie muss ich jedes Mal wenn einer sagt Boi.
Ich gehe sofort.
Endlich gehe ich sofort.
Gollof War.
Denken.
Warum sollte ich mich heiden?
Ich werde die Monster bashen.
Schreckt.
Da fliegt er.
Wie der steht wieder auf.
Der steht immer auf.
Schwerd haben wir schon.
Mal gucken ob hier oben noch irgendwas drin ist.
Dagger haben wir schon.
Geht das auf?
Hallo?
Ich erinnere mich irgendwo war hier ein Secret.
Da kann ich mir noch dunkel dran.
Es gab irgendwie am Anfang des Games ein Secret wo man richtig coole Waffe gekriegt hat.
Wenn man an einer Lampe oder so was gedrückt hat.
Ich weiß aber nicht mehr genau wo das gewesen ist.
Schreckt.
Jetzt kann ich gleich mal die coole Physik Sachen in dem Game zeigen.
Staff Sack das wollen wir nicht.
Foodration.
Nee das war glaube ich noch ein Stückchen weiter.
Ich muss mal kurz gucken ob der Stream ist nicht in 30 FPS oder?
Das war G-Bate.
Stimmt's?
Guck mal nach bitte.
Ich kann gerade nicht nachgucken weil ich nicht auf dem zweiten Bildschirm kann.
Der Stream müsste 1080p 8-Pitch-FPS sein.
Was 30?
Da muss ich jetzt doch mal gucken was da los ist.
Da muss ich mal kurz schauen auf den zweiten Rechner.
Sollte eigentlich 48 sein.
Das ist jetzt der mega G-Bate gerade von euch.
Ich kann gerade irgendwie nicht auf den zweiten Bildschirm warum nicht?
Jetzt.
Hä?
So alles gut.
Was erzählt ihr?
Digger.
Alles gut.
Kompletter G-Bate wieder.
Na gut auf dem iPhone keine Ahnung.
Das kann ich nicht zu sagen aber ihr müsst auf dem PC 48 FPS 1080p.
Eigentlich könnt ihr auch 60 FPS das nächste Mal machen.
Mein 8 MBit ist genug Upload.
So jetzt gucken wir uns mal die coole Half-Life.
Nicht Half-Life die Source Engine Physik Geschichten an die man machen kann.
Und danach müssen wir specken.
Ich mein guck mal wir haben 6 Skill Points.
Also entweder.
Ihr könnt euch ja mal überlegen.
Nach dem Files specken wir.
Ihr könnt euch ja mal überlegen was wir machen wollen.
Entweder gehen wir hier Richtung Stels.
Da müssen wir aber gleich direkt in Sneak Attacks specken.
Mit Dolch.
Oder wir gehen erstmal auf...
Also auf Magic habe ich keinen Bock.
Oder wir gehen erstmal auf Melee Combat inklusive den neuen Attacks.
Also sprich dass wir ordentlichen Charge kriegen.
Dass man ein Schild nehmen kann und sowas in der Richtung.
Ihr könnt euch ja mal überlegen was wir machen wollen.
Ob wir quasi die Dagger-Stels-Geschichte machen wollen.
Oder die Schwertschild-In-Your-Face-Geschichte.
Wobei die nicht exklusiv ist.
Das eine profitiert auch vom anderen.
Hätte ich jetzt Sneak Attack könnte ich den Typen halt von hinten wegstelsen.
Was ich halt so nicht kann.
Perfekt.
Guck man kann halt auch hier so...
Man kann denen halt auch die Kisten gegen den Kopf hauen.
Weil halt Source-Engine-Physik-Kram.
Was halt übelst Bock macht in dem Game.
Was ich so auch noch in keinem anderen Game gesehen habe.
Da ist er Down.
Bam.
So jetzt müssen wir mal gucken ob hier noch irgendwo ein bisschen Loot drinnen ist.
Warte da ist noch einer.
Achtung Feuer.
Ich will eben mal ins Feuer drehen.
Komm mal her.
Her komm, her komm, her komm, her komm, her komm, her komm, her komm, her komm.
Komm her.
Na.
Ok.
Fast.
Das sah jetzt zwar nicht so elegant aus, aber es hat prinzipiell funktioniert.
Das Feuer ist Schuld, genau.
Ok dann specken wir mal die Voraussetzungen für Stels.
Das ist nämlich ganz cool, wenn man stehen bleibt, dass man Sequence angezeigt kriegt.
Das ist ganz praktisch.
Daher kommt auch dieses Geklingel was man im Hintergrund hört.
Aber hier gibt es ansonsten nichts mehr.
Boom.
Big Shot.
Ok dann specken wir jetzt mal.
Also wir brauchen insgesamt 6 Skill Points um Stels Attack skillen zu können.
Und nachdem wir wahrscheinlich keinen einzelnen Skill Punkt kriegen, specken wir jetzt erstmal das hier für Power Attack.
Das geht nämlich auch mit Dollchen.
Also sprich das hier ist nicht nur für Schwert und Schild.
Ich kann jetzt zwar einen Schild nehmen auf dem nächsten Punkt, aber man kann jetzt quasi den Angriff Chargen.
So war es hier in der Richtung.
Mit Dollchen geht es im Endeffekt auch.
Also da profitiert alles von.
Das heißt beim nächsten 2 Skill Points specken wir Sneak Attack.
Au.
Achja übrigens eine Sache die ich auch am Anfang kann mir noch dran erinnern, das Games nie gecheckt habe ist dieser Kreis in der Mitte.
Da zeigt an wie gut man gestelzt ist.
Man sieht nämlich wenn man hier im Schatten ist, ist da der Kreis fast voll.
Und wenn man hier im Licht ist, dann ist der Kreis halt weg.
Also in der Mitte ist quasi unser Stellens Indikator.
Wenn ich das jetzt breake, oh wir schießen mal mit dem Bogen drauf.
Bogen in your face, Bogen im Kopf.
Konnte man nicht zoomen irgendwie?
Ich konnte doch zoomen, wartet mal, Controls, Bowzoom, R habe ich doch gedrückt.
Es könnte natürlich auch sein, dass mein Bow einfach keinen Zoom hat.
Oder dass die englische Tastatur rumspackt.
Oder die indische oder was auch immer gerade eingestellt ist.
Aber der Billigbogen hat einfach keinen Zoom.
Ja.
Nö das Ding hat einfach keinen Zoom.
Das ist einfach so da.
Guck mal auch wieder, was für ein Eidelsweiher, wie soll man damit treffen?
Ups.
Das war kein Headshot.
Bam.
Oh das ist schon down.
Schreckt.
Jetzt ist er down.
Gucken wir mal ob hier im Garten irgendwas drin ist.
Die Kampfmechanik ist halt super flüssig und macht übelst Bock.
Bam.
Also der steht nicht mehr auf.
War jetzt mal einer aus dem Fischer.
Den Zoom muss man skillen, ach so war das.
So gut kann ich mich dann immer dran erinnern.
Don't forget you can kick your enemies in fire. Würde ich machen, wenn ich noch ein Enemy hätte?
Kletter Sounds.
Dicht.
Jetzt haben wir hier Mana-Drank, Helz-Drank.
Nix drin.
Ich weiß nicht mal wo das war, irgendwo gab es so ein richtig geiles Item am Anfang.
Das ist mein Schlafzimmer, hier komme ich her.
Gut.
Weiter.
Loading.
Nicht crashen.
Nice, ist nicht gecrashed.
Good Job.
Ich weiß nicht ob ich jetzt Krach machen soll hier drin.
Werfen wir mal eine Schaufel, falls Gegner da sind.
Warum wackelt das so, immersion.
Fuck.
Ist hier irgendwas drin?
Das Zeug kann man anzünden, wenn man Feuerpfeile hat später.
Ich erinnere mich noch.
Wo, wo, die kicken wir jetzt irgendwo rein.
Zack, Zack, weg.
Au, das sieht aber auch gesund aus.
Ich hänge.
So, ähm, war das hier wo man?
Oho.
Noch immer.
Was ist hier drin?
Spoda.
Blatt gemacht.
Ich wollte das Ding gar nicht kicken.
Au.
Falle.
Na geil, jetzt habe ich eine Potion, die mir volles Held gibt.
Kann ich jetzt gleich reinhauen, weil mich die Falle geohnt hat.
Ganz, ganz grandioses Timing.
Bring es an Weihnachten.
Also, Dezember.
Ich habe hier wieder den ganzen Dezember Urlaub.
Das heißt, da werden wir wahrscheinlich fast jeden Tag stremen.
Stellt euch das mal vor.
Sachen gibt es, ha?
Okay, hier geht es lang.
Können wir die irgendwie besonders?
Besonders bashen?
Hier oben ist Zeug.
Wir locken die jetzt mal an.
Ja, natürlich hast du was gehört. Ich habe keine Kisten zerschlagen. Zwei Meter neben dir.
Ja, komm her.
Die billig Gegner können echt nichts. Die ersten Gegner sind echt billig, die können nichts.
Was haben wir hier drinnen?
Haben wir hier was? Bananas.
Dabei habe ich jetzt schon Full Health.
Übrigens, falls ich irgendwas über sehe, schreibt es einfach nochmal in den Chat.
So, geht es hier durch? Nope.
Von hier kommen wir. Das heißt, wir können jetzt da rum, oder?
Oh, da brennt was.
Boogie! Boogie muss zuerst dran glauben.
Zack!
Wie sie Slow-Motion machen.
Kann ich hier irgendwas? Irgendetwas zu looten?
Stärke der Gegner.
Ich muss mal kurz, ich will nicht irgendwo dagegenhauen, dass die mich hören.
Bäh!
Direkt!
Oh! Noch mehr.
Oh, die weichen hier auch aus.
Panzer am Start, ja richtig. Achtung!
Oh, komm! Lauf rein! Lauf rein!
Jaja, ist gut. Lauf rein! Lauf rein! Lauft rein!
Jeder hat keinen Bock rein zu laufen. Nehmen wir mal wieder das normale Schwert.
Geil vorbei gehauen, ne?
Uh! Kopf ab!
So, jetzt aber. Jetzt sind viel mehr Wachen da, als ich das in Erinnerung habe.
Ist das For Honor auf Low Quality?
Ich finde, das hat überhaupt keine Ähnlichkeit mit For Honor.
Fängt schon mal an, dass es nicht peer-to-peer gehostet ist.
Macht mir das Ding eigentlich Damage? Das muss ich mal kurz ausprobieren.
Okay, das macht mir Damage.
Was ist das für eine dünne Kreatur, die die Wand hochgelaufen ist?
Ja, man weiß es noch nicht.
Man weiß es noch nicht.
Was hat uns die Story bis jetzt noch nicht erzählt?
Wo? MonkaS!
Eigentlich wollte ich die Truhe öffnen.
Health Potion.
Zu? Zu?
Dein Schild habe ich schon. Aber Schilder sind eh nicht so geil.
Hier geht es nicht lang.
Hat der vielleicht eine Wache, einen Schlüssel oder so?
Nee.
Nee, sieht nicht so aus.
Kein Schlüssel. Das wird normalerweise auch angezeigt.
Auch nicht.
Auch nicht. Auch nicht.
Ah, doch. Die letzte Tür ist es natürlich.
Logisch, ne? Immer die letzte Tür.
Den müssen wir rushen.
Wir können ja auch versuchen zu out-bo gehen.
Na, meinst du es trifft den Kopf so?
Ach du Scheiße.
Okay, meine Bogen-Skills halten sich den ganzen.
Wo ist er?
Game? Crash! Yeah!
Nice Game. Gut gemacht.
Stabile Games in 2K18.
Kann man noch irgendwas runterstellen?
Also Anti-Lasing lassen wir auf jeden Fall an.
Nö, das ist eigentlich...
Eigentlich kann man da nichts mehr runterstellen.
Ich habe schon kein AF drinne.
Das Game hat ein bisschen ein Problem auf modernen Rechnern.
Also beziehungsweise das Problem hat es auch auf älteren Rechnern.
Das ist irgendwie ein 32-bit-Game.
Und die haben Probleme mit über 2GB.
Also sprich, sobald ihr Game mehr als 2GB RAM-Crab-Milch-Crashs.
Das heißt, man muss selbst auf dem Super-High-End-System das ein bisschen runterstellen.
Okay, gucken wir mal, ob wir ihn jetzt out-bo gehen können.
Jawoll!
In your face!
Was ist denn jetzt los?
Ach so, weil da unten Leichen sind.
Kommen sogar Mücken.
Nicht übel.
Immersion.
Auf und ein Daumen. Also die Immersion ist extrem hoch.
Wenn sogar Mücken kommen nach 2 Minuten.
Oh, den hat es ganz schön getackert.
Fast wie ein 4 mit dem Nadelwerfer.
Zack, zack, Kick.
Kannst du rumfallen?
Oh, da kommt der nächste.
Und zack.
Der lebt noch?
Das geht nur mit Dolchens, wenn ich das richtige Erinnerung habe.
Was haben wir hier?
Aha!
Da, ein Seil.
Nope.
Was haben wir hier oben?
Gibt es hier was Gutes?
Gibt es hier irgendwas Gutes?
Hier ist doch überhaupt nichts, oder?
Woa, wie kommt der hier hin?
Komm her.
Kick.
Kick, flieg runter.
Der fliegt nicht runter.
Alter, kannst du?
Ok, der hat keinen Bock runter zu fliegen.
Jetzt.
Jetzt aber.
Guck mal, hier kommt man sonst nicht dahinter, oder?
Geh weg.
Aha, nice.
So, gibt es hier sonst noch irgendwas zu looten?
Ich würde mal sagen, nee.
Hier, das Level ist vorbei.
Ups.
Ja, wir haben noch ein paar Pfeile, ein paar Bogen.
Nee, nix.
Gehen wir raus.
Oh, hier geht es rein, oder?
Ach nee, hier kann man über die Dächer stelsen.
Das ist, wenn man hier schon Sneak Attack und Gedönsgespekt hat.
Oh, Secret Mana Potions.
Die keiner braucht, weil ich keine Spells habe.
Jawoll.
Yeah.
Äh, Griechen?
Also nicht die aus Odyssey?
Äh, ok, Moment, wo müssen wir einschlagen?
Ah, Moment, jetzt bin ich hier an der Aferstirm.
Hier, das ist hier, wo ich...
Oh, fuck.
Hier bin ich doch eben hochgegangen.
Auf, hoch und dann gehen wir da weiter, wo die komische Wache gewesen ist.
Oh, nice, Level vorbei.
Das Game sieht interessanter aus, das ging an dir vorbei.
Nee, das Game ist von 2008.
Also, Siti, ich weiß ja nicht, wann du schon spielst, aber vielleicht hattest du das einfach nicht auf dem Radar, weil das vor deiner Zeit war.
Achtung, Achtung, Achtung, Achtung.
Was?
Das hört sich schon unangenehm an, oder?
Bottle of Juice?
The Juice?
XQC könnte das bestimmt gut erklären, was The Juice ist.
Weil, muss ich ehrlich sagen, ich guck eigentlich doch relativ selten Overwatch-Geschichten.
Ich hab mir das so überguckt.
Guck mal, das Ding schwingt immer noch.
Das haben wir gefühlt vor einer halben Stunde angehauen und es schwingt immer noch.
Oh, da blinkt was.
Das blinkt da, wie soll ich da hinkommen?
Das sieht nicht so aus, als möchte das Game, dass ich da schon hinne komme, oder?
Nee.
Rein, rein, rein, rein.
Oh.
So, wir haben noch keinen Sneak Attack, ne?
Kein Sneak Attack.
Nee, wir haben auch nicht genug Skill-Punkte fürs Sneak Attack.
Das heißt, uns bleibt im Prinzip nichts anderes übrig, wie...
IN YOUR FACE!
Oh!
Ah!
What the fuck?
Da bin ich richtig, du aber nicht mehr lang.
Zack, Bam!
Rekt!
Die machen nix mehr.
So, erst mal gucken, ob es hier noch schön Loot gibt.
Was haben wir hier? Öl? Brauchen wir nicht.
Ziemlich coole Mechaniken.
Jaja, das ist nice.
Es mir fällt kein anderes Game ein in dieser Richtung.
Und man kann es halt auch nicht wirklich mit Skyrim vergleichen, einfach weil es Ego-Kampf hat.
Ist komplett anders, ne?
Also, wahrscheinlich wären das die, wie gesagt, die die Skyrim gespielt haben.
Im Prinzip hat wahrscheinlich außer mir jeder Skyrim gespielt.
Ähm, zumindest. Mehr als fünf Minuten.
Ähm, bestätigen können, dass das nicht viel mit Skyrim gemeint hat.
Vom Kampf her.
Aha.
Was ist hier?
Strafzimmer.
Mana-Pots. Nee, Health-Pots.
Nope.
Haben wir hier irgendwas drinne?
Noch mehr Mana-Pots, die man nicht braucht.
Auch nix. Nix.
Ja, hast du.
Au.
Ähm, ich sollte mich mal heilen.
Ich sollte mich mal heilen.
Futterfutter, Social-Eating-Stream.
Vielleicht die Banane aufheben.
Ich geh jetzt nicht weiter.
Okay, das Game möchte von uns, dass wir hier langgehen.
Das war down, der krasse Mage.
Oh.
Wir können skillen.
Ähm.
Ja.
Soll ich den jetzt verfolgen oder skillen?
Ähm.
Verfolgen.
Alter, Game, was los?
Was ist dein Problem, Game?
Alter, das Game, das mein Meme-Bot macht, das Game kaputt, glaube ich, habe ich das Gefühl. Kann das sein?
Schneller.
Kletter.
Verfolgungsmission.
Und ich wette mit euch, in der Verfolgungsmission, ich kann ihn gar nicht fangen.
Ich kann ihn, selbst wenn ich will, kann ich ihn nicht fangen.
Fable Lost Chapters, das habe ich noch nicht gespielt.
Äh, wo geht's lang?
Ja, das seh ich auch.
Alter, kannst du mal reinklettern?
Äh.
Ach, da.
Zack, zack, zack.
Ich kann nicht hinterher, ich habe kein Endo mehr.
Wie kann man Fable nicht gespielt haben, das habe ich gesehen, ich habe ganz viele Sachen nicht gespielt.
Wo?
Rennen.
Jaja, man kann das Ding nicht treffen, das ist so typische Verfolgungsmission, die man nicht gewinnen darf.
Was geht? Ich muss weg.
Ja, aber Fable ging echt an mir vorbei.
Kommt möglicherweise noch ein Video zu World War 3?
Oh, hier muss man ran, okay.
Ja, wenn ich es endlich mal gespielt habe, ich wollte es ja am Samstag oder so schon spielen, als rauskommt, ist ja mittlerweile die Server down.
Au.
Wo geht's lang? Hier.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Monka Giga.
Source Engine Physik Rätsel.
Kann doch einfach drüber laufen.
Hier.
Ach, geschafft. Nice.
Jaja, World War 3 ist draußen.
Ich habe es beim Lost ein bisschen geguckt.
Der Eindruck, dass es ein Battlefield-Abklatsch ist, also im positiven Sinn, hat sich nicht bestätigt.
Das Game spielt sich wohl eine ganze Ecke langsamer als Battlefield, also es scheint doch ein bisschen was eigenständiges zu sein.
Infiltrate the Warehouse.
Oh, Skill-Punkt. Leute, jetzt wird geskillt. Jetzt muss gespeckt werden.
Das war eine nice Verfolgung, ja.
Okay, Sneak Attack, ne?
Stealth, Leute.
Wollen wir?
Stealth-Spec.
Wir können Stealth, wir haben neun Skill-Punkte, das heißt, wir können Stealth specken und den zweiten Angriff hier.
Oh, das ist cool.
Da waren wir das doch.
Stealth Archer, ne?
Bogenkram ist in dem Game übelst OP.
Also, an sich, ich zeige euch das mal.
An sich ist Bogenkram schlecht.
Das Problem ist halt, du kannst dich halt an sowas wie hier stellen und alle Gegner ownen, wo sie nicht hochkommen.
Der Dude hat mich gesehen. Wollt ihr mich verarschen?
Ich kann nämlich gesehen haben.
Okay, specken wir.
Also, specken wir Stealth.
Stealth Nummer zwei.
Dann haben wir Sneak Attack.
Und wir specken Mehle Combat für Schild.
Dann können wir nämlich Shield ausrüsten.
Und mit Dagger können wir schön wegstelzen.
Wo ist denn der Typ hin?
Achtung jetzt, Stealth Stream.
Wo ist er denn? Eben war er doch noch da.
Hallo.
Ich geh jetzt mal in die andere Richtung gucken, was da so ist.
Closed.
Pilze.
Ah, ein Hintereingang, verstehe.
Aber, was Hintereingang ist, ist unsinnig.
Wir wollen keinen Hintereingang.
Wir sind zwar ein Stelze, aber wir sind ein Offensive Stelze.
Also sprich, wir stelzen uns zu den...
Oh fuck, das geht ja gar nicht auf.
Dann machen wir das vielleicht doch nicht jetzt.
Wie soll man da hinstelzen?
Ich werd doch mal durch den Hintereingang gehen.
Übrigens, achtet mal drauf, ne?
Das ist ein Game, wo man stelzen kann, ohne dass es Stelzindikator, Minimap, Versteck, Gefahrenanzeige und sonst was gibt.
Hier muss man auch auf gut Glück stelzen, dass das funktioniert.
Oh, wir sind hier mitten im Gegnergebiet.
Jetzt kommt eine krasse Stelze in die Aktion.
Du kannst mich überhaupt nicht hören.
Du kannst mich nicht hören.
Das ist per Definition unmöglich, mich zu hören.
So, wie Sneak Attacken wir die Dudes denn jetzt am besten?
Wie Sneak Attacken wir die jetzt am besten?
Ah, den da oben Sneak Attacken wir jetzt.
Der will schon richtig von uns Sneak Attacken werden.
Oh fuck, das müssen wir noch mal machen.
Ich will den Sneak Attacken, ich will den richtig, richtig dolchen.
Wie machen wir das jetzt? Sneak Attack?
Einmal will ich Sneak Attacken, wenn ich jetzt schon Respekt habe.
Ich gehe mal wieder in den Schatten.
Oh Mann, Alter, was soll das denn?
Stellst du die Sau weg? Ja, mache ich, mache ich.
Ich stelle dich jetzt sowas von weg.
Wo ist er?
Was? Alter!
Ha, gestellst!
Omega-Stellsetack, ja.
Da oben ist Loot.
Alter, wie die mich sehen.
Wie die mich sehen.
Egal, genug gestellst.
Tja.
Die können ja auch nichts. Wie? Der Typ hat es überlebt?
Stop, es geht los.
Jetzt aber, zack!
Achtung, da, das lassen wir jetzt noch einstürzen.
Oh, schön drauf.
Kiste, Kopf.
Da sind aber ganz schön viele.
Wieder ausweicht.
Ha, wie ist das denn geflogen? Habt ihr es gesehen, das Messer?
Die machen Damage.
Die machen echt krass Damage.
Hätte ich nicht gedacht.
Hallo, Schild.
Ich kann gleich wieder was futtern und Health Packs reinhauen.
Oh, der wird erstellst jetzt.
Und, Stelzattack!
Jawoll.
Oh, was ist das denn? Ein Longbow und ein Stelzer-Crab.
Bringt das plus Armor. Sehr nice.
Teller.
Braucht dann sowas. The Juice brauchen wir.
So, jetzt gehen wir in das Warehouse und weiter geht's.
Oh, war da was? Ach nee, das ist die Tonne.
Ich muss euch mal was fragen.
Ich hab's in der letzten Stream schon mal versucht irgendwie anzusprechen, aber irgendwie ist mir dann was dazwischen gekommen.
Was guckt ihr denn eigentlich für Let's Player?
Oder hab ich das letzte Stream schon erzählt? Hä, was ist denn das hier?
Weil ich hab das Problem, ich würd mir manchmal ganz gern ein paar Spiele angucken und halt nicht unbedingt selbst spielen, aber irgendwie
mich nerven die meisten Let's Player außer Dance Game.
Das ist der Einzige, den ich mir angucken kann.
Von dem kann ich mir im Prinzip fast alles angucken.
Aber wahrscheinlich, weiß nicht, wahrscheinlich weil das so in meinem Alter ist irgendwie.
Oder was heißt Dance Game? Dance Gaming.
Das ist der Einzige, den ich mir angucken kann.
Schon lange eigentlich.
Und eigentlich nur ihn. Und sonst kaum.
Kronk kann ich mir nicht angucken, das liegt aber nicht an Kronk, sondern weil die Let's Plays relativ, weil die im Prinzip mir zu langsam sind.
So nach dem Motto, wir brauchen fürs erste Level 5 Tage, das dreh ich durch.
Hier oben hat eben was geklitzert, ne?
Hey, das funktioniert! Nice.
Source Engine FTW. Was haben wir denn hier zu bieten?
Lone Skin, Full Health Potion und Ring of Phoenix.
Alles klar, das ist nice.
Weil sie einmal plus eins leben.
So, mehr gibt's hier glaub ich nicht.
Was ist das da?
Ja, wie gesagt, ich guck bei Kronk die Let's Plays nicht, weil ich Kronk nicht gucken will, sondern weil sie mir zu langsam ist.
Ansonsten ist er mir von deutschen Let's Playern, quasi als von denen, die ich kenne, von seiner Art her noch am liebsten, aber das geht mir einfach zu langsam.
Oh, wir haben Skill Pals.
Das glaub ich der sofort.
Demon Grills. So sind sie.
Eine Forge.
Steelbar.
Oh, kann ich jetzt forgen?
Oh nice, nice Leute, wir forgen jetzt.
Wir lassen die Wachen mal da rumlaufen, ist egal. Jetzt wird geforged.
Zack.
Nein.
Hammer.
Ah, Puss.
Blown.
Krasse Crafting Action hier.
Ist es geschmolzen? Jo.
Oh, diese Immersion Leute, ich sag's euch, diese Immersion.
Blade is not hot enough, okay.
Ist das jetzt fertig?
Was ist das?
Sword Hills.
Ein Langschwert, nice.
Ha, sind wir super equipt.
Jetzt wird geschreckt.
Zu Zeiten, wo die Source Engine angesagt war, hatten ganz viele Spiele so kleine Physik Rätselchen und so.
Sowas gibt's aktuell gar nicht, ne?
Blade is not hot.
Nice joke, Blade is not hot, der ist gut.
Die wollte, ich will nämlich nicht an den vorbeischleichen, ich will die bashen.
Vor allem jetzt hab ich ein neues Schwert, ne?
Ring of Arcane.
Ups, ich hab rausgetappt.
Inventory auf Tab ist auch ganz schön beknackt.
Na, 10 Mana, lull Mana.
Wer bitte braucht Mana?
Oh, Manni.
Was ist da los? Muss ich nachgucken?
Ich hab gehört, dass einer donated hat.
2 Euro für das geile Game und deine Stimme von It's Adi, Dankeschön.
Ja, irgendwann bin ich auch mal Twitch-Partner.
Ich weiß, ich sag's schon seitdem, ich bin ein Dreivierteljahr oder so.
Da komm ich dir nicht her, doch.
Ich mag aber Inventar auf Tab nicht, warum kann man Inventar nicht einfach auf I machen, so wie das alle machen.
In dem Game ist es besonders schlimm, weil Schleichen ist halt...
Haben die mich gesehen?
Ach, das ist die Spinne.
Die machen die Musik wegen der Spinne an, ernsthaft.
Achtung, eine kleine Spinne kommt angekrabbelt.
Spoder.
Noch mehr Spoders.
Einfach drüber laufen, auch gut.
Ich will die Gegner nicht umlaufen, wartet Leute.
Ich muss noch mal zu, ich will die Gegner bashen.
Warum soll ich denn die... Warum in der Welt sollte ich denn die Gegner umlaufen?
Warum sollte ich das denn machen? Ich hab mir ein neues Schwert geforscht.
Und mit dem neuen Schwert muss natürlich die Gegner jetzt gebashed werden.
Warum sollte ich die Gegner denn umlaufen wollen?
Ich bin total bescheuert.
Siehst du, neue Schwerte am Start, instant Gegner gebashed.
Sowas zu sein. Guck mal, außerdem verpasse ich so viele Türen und so viel Loot.
Ring of Weapon Master.
5% Chance, Critical Health. Ich bleib mal hier auf meinen...
Chain, nice.
Chainmail, Endurance 1.
Endurance, Endurance, wo ist Endurance?
Endu, Endu, wo kann man Endu specken?
4 Punkte.
Also Chainmail wäre schon sehr, sehr nice.
Oh, noch ein neues Schwert. Wird hier immer besser.
Critical Hit 1, plus 3 Damage.
Chainmail hat schon plus 3 Damage, das brauch ich nicht.
Sonst so irgendwas?
Nope.
Hier komm ich her.
Oh, noch ne Tür.
Noch mehr Loot bestimmt, Loot.
Eine Note.
Jaja.
Tell me more please.
Nice Dagger.
Der braucht Stells 3. Stells 3 hab ich ewig nicht.
Da brauch ich 10 Skillpunkte für.
Das wird nix.
Ok, weiter geht's.
Siehste, warum hätte ich die Gegner umlaufen sollen?
Richtig dumm.
Ah, Gatschi Emoz. Alle, alle hab ich.
Habs alle am Start.
Das hab ich extra bei der TwitchTV Premium gekauft.
Wegen der Spielmechanik wäre das vielleicht...
Na, viele Source Games haben so ein bisschen Physikkram, aber...
Achtung, wir machen es jetzt so.
Wir werfen es dem gegen Kopf.
Und den anderen, den anderen, wenn der herkommt, komm her.
Der hat grad seinen Kollege plattge...
Bist du dumm?
Was ist mit dem los?
Hat er mich nicht gesehen oder was?
Oh, ist der blöd.
Ist der blöd.
Ja, ganz bestimmt.
For sure, for sure. Mach mal.
Achtung, ich stells dich jetzt.
Bam.
Und für den Swag.
Das Spiel bietet echt einen Haufen Möglichkeiten.
Jaja, es gibt kein anderes Game, was mir einfällt in dieser Richtung.
Das versteh ich gar nicht, weil das ist schon...
Das ist quasi so der...
Heutzutage würde das Game nicht mehr Dark Messiah of Mind Magic heißen,
sondern heute würde es irgendwie... keine Ahnung...
Kill Simulator oder sowas heißen.
Bringst du auch noch so ein Ding, was viele Games damals hatten, eine Konsole?
Heute würde es Kill Simulator heißen.
Weil sich Simulatoren ja heute super verkaufen.
So, jetzt sind wir hier, wo wir oben rausgekommen wären sonst.
Warte, ich muss mal kurz was gucken.
F5?
Wie sie sich alle drüber lustig machen, dass ich mich verschrieben hab in meinem YouTube-Post.
Auf Rechtschreibfehler springen alle immer super an.
Eigentlich müsste man Rechtschreibfehler absichtlich reinmachen,
wenn man will, dass Leute reagieren.
Wer hätte das gedacht, dass Gefangenen versuchen zu entkommen, wenn man die Zellentür öffnet?
Ernsthaft?
Da kann man nicht drauf kommen.
Okay, ich muss ihn ablenken.
Ja, schrei nicht so rum, halt die Klappe!
Cool, ich mach die Zellentür auf, ne?
Das ist halt Source Engine, das merkt man gleich.
Ich find auch Source Engine Games sehen heute immer noch gut aus.
Dank ihm ja.
Ich hab nur gerade in meiner Vorschau gesehen, dass ich immer im Tunnel den Gaben drin hab.
So, jetzt, ha?
Weggestellt!
Wie er immer schnauft.
Ich find's im Fantasy Games immer geil, dass die Börsen so richtig ein Dorf sind, ja?
Oh, mehr Demon Grill.
Was?
Rot?
Alter!
Ich wusste doch, dass da noch Demon Grill kommt.
Die haben so gut gevoist.
Also die hat ne gute Voice Actress.
Das kauft man da richtig ab.
Das ist Demon Grill.
Na klar.
Na klar können wir das.
Warum genau muss man das eigentlich wieder zumachen?
Ich weiß jetzt ja nicht so, dass das ne Tür ist, das ist ne Kiste, die sie da Magic verschiebt.
Stebe sind kacke und nachdem es in dem Game keinen Shop gibt, lassen wir die einfach liegen.
Schiff.
Alter!
Ist ja gut, regt euch ab, müsst gleich eskalieren.
Nicht gleich eskalieren, Leute.
Da kommt was.
Ha, null.
Nope.
Direkt.
Ah, verstehe.
Hä?
Bewegt sich das nicht?
Doch, jetzt.
Hart rumgebackt.
Ja, es ist witzig, dass Wachen direkt sterben, wenn es ins Wasser kommt, ne?
Oh mein Gott, ich bin nass.
Oh, da liegt noch ein Kopf.
Schleckte.
Ich hab da oben gerade was gehört.
Also, da können wir nicht raus.
Da können wir nicht raus.
Wenn die da oben rumlaufen.
Ach, der Typ ist natürlich so doof und geht die Leiter runter, da kann ich ihn schön wegstellen.
Achtung! Achtung!
Stellsteck!
Oh, das hat er gehört? Hat er das gehört?
Den stellsten wär jetzt auch.
Der Stellsteck!
Gib Ribs.
Gut, dass wir Stellsteck gespeckt haben.
Mana brauch ich nicht.
Ich find's cool, ne?
Es kriegt in diesem Schiff keiner mit, wenn ich hier einen Wahnsinnskrach mache beim Kisten zerlegen.
Das ist egal.
Aber dreh dich auf das falsche Holz, da kommen sofort alle Wachen an.
So, nein, da war jemand.
Aber, just RPG things.
Äh, wo geht's weiter?
Wo geht's weiter?
Ach, da.
Geh auf.
Oh, Loot.
Den haben wir schon, diesen komischen Ring.
Den brauchen wir nicht nochmal.
Stellsteck.
Food Rations.
Ja, fottern wir mal was, dass wir ein bisschen Health kriegen.
Was haben wir eigentlich für Alexiere?
Health Potion, 10 Health, okay.
Wir haben einen Magic Mushroom, der kompletten Health und Mana wieder aufrückt.
Das ist natürlich auch sehr nice.
Stellsteck, Stellsteck.
Müssen wir, müssen wir stelsen.
Mach nicht so einen Krach.
So, wie, wie stelsen wir die jetzt am besten?
Die scheinen sich nicht zu bewegen.
Kann man die hochklettern, vielleicht?
Max, was hast du eigentlich nach der Ausbildung gemacht, also Weiterbildung, ETC?
Ich hab erstmal da weitergearbeitet, wo ich die Ausbildung gemacht hab.
Ich glaub, 2 oder 3 Jahre und damit schon anders sind.
Ah, nice, nice, nice. Der kommt runter, da kann er erstellst werden.
Achtung, Stellsteck.
Stellsteck.
Das hat er nicht gehört, oder was?
Ein Hook.
Taugt ihm.
Alter, das, warum Inventar? Warum Inventar auf Tab?
Ob das was taugt?
Das hört er bestimmt nicht, wenn man hier alles kaputt schlägt.
Doch.
Der Hook ist nice.
Der Hook regelt.
Sonst gibt es hier nichts mehr.
Halt die Klappe. Schrei nicht so rum, wenn ich stellsten will.
Ich muss weg.
Stells. Oh, Stellsteck.
Wisst ihr was?
Scheiß auf Stells.
Ein Key, damit kann ich die Goblins aufschließen.
Oder auch nicht. Wie kann man die Goblins aufmachen?
Lasst mich in Ruhe. Ich hab euch befreit.
Oh, der wird geschreckt von denen jetzt.
Will er mich jetzt bashen?
Alter, was soll das?
Was soll das? Werden sie befreit und schon wenden sie sich gleich gegen den, der sie befreit hat.
Das ist auch Goblin Logik.
Aber der Hook geht ab, oder?
Kommst du her?
Weggehooked.
Alter, was ist los?
Kann man den Hook eigentlich mit Schild verwenden?
Das ist fast wie Roadhog.
Ah, zumachen kann man nicht mehr.
Und hiermit hätte man wahrscheinlich auch noch was bashen können.
Das haben sie schon nice gemacht.
Hier haben wir wirklich viele Möglichkeiten.
Scrolls.
Mal kurz was futtern.
Bisschen Health.
Nice.
Okay, sonst ist hier nichts mehr drinne.
Hier noch was.
Wisst ihr was ich ganz cool finde an Games von früher?
Also das eine, was mir gerade auffällt, ist wieder, dass sie einfach...
Ah, super, jetzt haben wir uns das gerade schön gecraftet.
Und jetzt gibt es das hier als Drop.
Ich finde lineare Games haben auch ihren Vorzug.
Jetzt nix gegen Open World Games an sich.
Games mit einem roten Faden sind auch nicht schlecht.
Immer unsere Dolche, weil wir noch Stelz Attack machen müssen.
Stelz Attack.
Wie hast du mich gesehen?
Wie hat er mich gesehen?
Die Tür ist zu.
Ja, ist klar.
Kann man den dann auch durch die Tür killen?
Nee, das geht natürlich nicht.
Bam.
Wieder lebt noch.
Aber nicht mehr lang.
Okay, Giftschwert.
Ja, mit dem Schwert geht das gleich.
Besser.
Ordentliche Waffe.
Eigentlich wollte ich Stelzen, aber die Gegner haben da irgendwie strich durch die Rechnung gemacht.
Ah, was ist das denn?
Ein Elfenbogen.
Plus zwei Critical Hits habe ich nicht.
Zack.
Kann man den irgendwie Kopf abhauen?
Nicht wirklich.
Oh, Skillpoints. Wir können schon mal überlegen, was wir als nächstes backen.
Wie kommt man hier in die Mitte? Hier in der Mitte ist noch Loot.
Oh, hier ist es verschlossen.
Da müsste doch irgendeine Wache jetzt...
Scheiß auf Loot, das bisschen.
Oder finden wir irgendwie einen Weg hier rein?
Da hat doch bestimmt irgendeine Wache mit Schlüssel bei.
Wie kommen wir hier rein?
Ich meine, die Tür ist...
Die Tür ist dicht.
Wache, Schlüssel? Nope.
Hier ist auch dicht.
Ach komm, scheiß drauf.
Paar Kisten da.
Wozu?
Oder checkt irgendjemand, wie man da reinkommt?
Vielleicht hier rum?
Nee, hier sind wir gesporn.
Die Wache hat auch nix dabei gehabt.
Schlüssel?
Ah, nice.
Easy.
Mal kurz bisschen geguckt.
Sehr schön.
Looten.
Lootenbeste.
Ein nicees Loot.
Was haben wir denn hier?
Scrolls, die keiner braucht.
Mana-Tränke, die keiner braucht.
Schinken, den man braucht.
Und nochmal Mana-Tränke, die keiner braucht.
Und hier haben wir...
Hier sind wir gesporn.
Oder? Ist das unser Spornraum?
Ja, das ist unser Spornraum.
Okay, das hat es jetzt nicht so gebracht.
Not wrecked, wrecked, really wrecked, get wrecked, Tyrannosaurus wrecked.
Ja, das ist...
Tyrannosaurus wrecked ist für mich auch die beste Rektabwandlung, die es so gibt.
Nee, hier lang.
Was haben wir denn so?
Kann man hier irgendwas drehen?
Oh, wir müssen Stelz-Mode activate.
Oh, es ruckelt.
Ich kann mich gerade erinnern, das hat auch damals auf meinem Rechner geruckelt.
Schifflevel ist anscheinend nicht...
Oh nee, das hat er mich gesehen, ich wollte ihn doch gerade erstelzen.
Come on, bra.
Bruh, was ist da los?
Lass das nicht so lange andauern wie Half-Life.
Hast du in den letzten Stream geguckt?
Jetzt wird am Stück durchgespielt.
Okay, das werden wir heute nicht schaffen, am Stück.
So viel kann ich sagen.
Achtung, die werden jetzt erstellt.
Okay, wird auch nicht erstellt.
Moment, meinst du, lass mich weg?
Wo ist der Hook?
Steam Overlay.
Hook.
Nächster.
Rekt, Alter.
Positioning ist alles.
Der Hook owns alle.
Ich mag das Demon Grill.
Und die sprechen jetzt auch gut.
Die bringen das echt gut rüber.
Warum geht's hier nicht auf?
Ich will hier rein.
Lass mich rein.
Wort von gestern ist auch schon verfügbar.
Sehr nice.
Zebaro ist wieder on point.
Hier darf ich hochklettern, aber weiter nicht, ne?
Weiter ist nicht erlaubt.
Geht's hier irgendwo rein?
War hier unten noch ne Tür?
Was muss ich denn machen?
Ich muss die Brücke runter machen.
Wo ist denn die Brücke?
Hier?
Ach, da.
Ist voll offensichtlicher.
Irgendwie sieht das mit dem Haken schon leicht lächerlich aus, oder?
Aber der Haken ist nice.
Stylish ist natürlich schon mit dem Langschwert.
Dieser Grill ist auch am Start.
Äh, Mr. Milchmann, das ist so.
Oh, Gegner.
Ich muss an die Ballistas.
Lass mich rein.
Ballista Bash.
Jeder.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, jeder Shooter.
Das ist ja kein Shooter.
Jedes Spiel aus Ego-Perspektive braucht eine.
Braucht mindestens eine Einlage mit automatischem Geschützen.
Wenn man jetzt treffen würde, wäre natürlich auch ganz nice.
Oh, rekt.
Die hat's zerrissen.
Oh, die hat's auch zerrissen.
Bisschen mehr Foff könnte ich gebrauchen.
Oh, die zerreißt auch.
Bisschen mehr Foff wäre nicht verkehrt.
Alter, die Burgis own die komplett.
Wie er wegfetzt.
Die Burgis own die komplett.
Was ist hier los?
Hat die sich gerade geheilt, kann es sein?
Und die treffen auch gut.
Achtung, gleich kommt er hier.
Bam.
Oh, fuck.
Ich dachte, man kann zoomen oder so.
Kann man aber nicht.
Da fliegt er.
Auch easy.
Ich dachte...
Das hätte auch ein bisschen gehen können.
Das war doch ganz lustig.
Ich bilde mir ein, Leute.
Es gab hier auf dem Schiff noch Crafting-Material.
Das habe ich noch so im Hinterkopf.
Man konnte später eine richtig coole Waffe craften.
Und das Crafting-Material war irgendwo hier auf dem Schiff.
Aber ich habe keine Ahnung mehr, wo.
Vielleicht weiß das ja noch einer von euch, der das gespielt hat.
Ansonsten werden wir ohne auskommen müssen.
Was für Spiele spielst du noch?
Und wie lange geht der Stream?
Ja, also der Stream.
Für spätestens 22 Uhr, da muss ich pennen.
Was wir sonst noch so spielen, kann ich dir erzählen?
Die zwei Krills mögen sich.
Natürlich.
Ja, aber was wir sonst noch so spielen, wollen wir hier kurz zwischengeworfen.
Ich habe mir nämlich eine Liste gemacht mit allen Sachen, die mir so eingefallen sind,
die in Frage kommen.
Da haben wir z.B.
Bad Company 1 Kampagne, Titanfall 2 Kampagne, Battlefield 3.
Also es geht mir immer um den Singleplayer.
Also Kampagne.
Let's play, ich stell's.
Battlefield 3, Battlefield 4, CoD 4.5, MW2, Black Ops 1, Back Ops The Line,
Soldier of Fortune 2, Dark Nassiah 4.
Da sind wir gerade dabei, 4 hatten wir gestern.
Far Cry 1, Far Cry 3, Crysis 1, Max Payne 1 und 2, Shadow Warrior, Bioshock, Dishonored,
Dead Space 1, nur 1.
Black Mesa, Half Life 2, Metro, Stalker und Dark Project.
Oder das Remake, mal gucken.
Ja, das heißt wir sind für die nächsten 10 Jahre beschäftigt.
Ungefähr, oder?
Oh!
Da ist ein Loch.
Diesen Ring hab ich jetzt schon 3 Mal, ne?
Kann man Titanic machen?
Nee, kann man nicht.
Na dann gehen wir mal zu Lea rein.
Oder wie heißt er eigentlich genau?
Leana.
Lassen wir uns mal erzählen, was Leana Wichtiges mit uns zu besprechen hat.
Ich darf nicht raus, oder?
Den Anker lichten.
Alles klar.
Wir lichten den Anker.
Der Sebaro, da packt er wieder die Emotes aus.
Ja Leute, was sagt ihr?
Wizard Grill oder Demon Grill?
Ich persönlich bin ja für Demon Grill.
Alter Chat, reißt euch mal zusammen.
Warum nicht beide, weil das nicht geht.
Spodermann.
Oh!
Wut?
Zum Glück alles nur Traum.
Der Rock, der ist wirklich unglücklich geschnitten.
Ist das der Typ von Half Life 1?
Was?
Wer?
Der?
Nee.
Was?
Richtig ab?
Oh, das ist anscheinend nicht erlaubt.
Okay, ich hab nichts gemacht.
Dragon.
Es echoed sogar.
Habt ihr das gehört?
Ich hab das gehört.
Was ist das für ein Zauberlehrling?
Schreckt!
Orks, was können Orks schon?
Nix
Nix können Orks, guckt's euch an
Noob Orks
Get cooked
Noob Orks! Get cooked!
Wo ist der nächste Ork?
Moment Leute, ich lade mal, den hätten wir schön stellskillen können
Deswegen ist gar nicht viel, wir sind ja quasi grade split-specked
Wir können ja Stels und Mele machen
What?
Stels Attack hat nicht funktioniert
Das ist schlecht, wenn Stels und Mele nicht funktioniert
Der Ork da oben sieht ein bisschen geklitscht aus
Alter Ork macht Damage!
Ork macht richtig gut Damage
Der Ring hat uns gehealt
Jetzt aber
Flup, geklitscht der Orks, auch down
Wir können sie auch hooken die Orks, Roadhog Style
Oh, ein Orkschwert oder Orkschild, nice
Taugt das Orkschild was?
Nee, das sagt
Strength 2
Ein Skillpunkt fehlt uns noch
Ein Skillpunkt fehlt uns noch für das Orkschwert
Warten wir mal
Oh, da oben
Den Counter bogen wir jetzt
Au
Alter, ich bin kein guter Bogenschütze
Nein, das wird nix
Hook, weg hooken
Was ist das?
Scroll
Bashen
Hooken, bam
Bam
Und
Oh, Hand ab
Oh, mehr, mehr Orks, ich hol mal mein Schwert raus
Triple Orks
Attacke
Vor, vorbei
Oh, bam
Nice
Schreckt
Ich hab ihn entwaffnet
Okay, bereits
Der holt seine Waffe, nee, nee, nee, du holst nicht deine Waffe
Doch, du holst seine Waffe
Die Orks, Alter, die Orks gehen ab
Oh, ich hab ihn entwaffnet
Ich hab ihn entwaffnet
Die Orks wollen's echt wissen
Nice
Okay, jetzt können wir Stranks becken
War man das doch?
Nee, wir können nicht Stranks becken, wir müssen erst mal diesen kackjes becken
Scheiße
Hoch
Das mich aber erschreckt
Das ist hier, das war typisch Grill
Wirft das hier um und fragt mich ob ich verrückt bin
So war's aber auch
Okay
Okay, ähm
Nee, das ist scheiße
Das ist zu viel Stealth, ich brauch Stealth für Sneak Attack und ansonsten nix
Wir specken Melee Combat
Wir specken Melee Combat und Strength
Okay, wir können leider nur uns fehlen vier Skill Points, dass wir das Orkschwert nehmen können
Entweder specken wir Stranks eins oder wir specken Endu eins, dann können wir nämlich gleich die Kettenrüstung anziehen
Leute, was sagt ihr?
Kettenrüstung oder sparen auf Orkschwert?
Also im Prinzip ist jetzt die Ausfall zwischen mehr Rüstung oder mehr Damage
Damage
Yes
Yes ist keine valide Antwort
Was wollt ihr, A oder B?
Ja
Dann zaubern wir mal auf
Oh, Tunnel, Tunnelstalls
Hallo Cheesy Pro, Spodas
So viele Spodas
Spoda Rotface
Was ist das?
Alter, was ist das?
Fliegen dort hinten Fische
Ach, wir haben jetzt ja auch ein Head Strike am Stadion, jawoll
Rotface
Was ist das hier?
Strafe Action
Strafe ist stark in mir
Helds
Äh, da oder da?
Du bist ein toller Mörder, nicht wahr?
Du wirst nicht brauchen, dass Rudel.
Nimm es einfach.
Ich bin mir sicher, dass es nötig wird.
Hier.
Also wenn man mit dem Ding gegen Holz schießt, dann gibt's nen Seil.
Was sehr, sehr nice ist.
Oh.
Secret?
Lol.
Secret.
Ich dachte, hier geht's lang.
Omega-Lull.
OMG-Iga-Lull.
Es wird mal Zeit, dass irgendwie einer den Omega-Lull-Song macht.
Weil den Kappa-Song gibt's ja schon.
A... da oben.
Äh...
Das ist nicht wie Pfeile fliegen.
Das ist nicht, wie Pfeile fliegen.
Ah ja, so fliegen Pfeile, das ist okay.
Yeah!
Äh.
Hab ich Item übersehen?
Ach nee, ich muss da dran ziehen.
Easy.
Oh, die Orks, die wurden richtig geschreckt gerade.
Tür zu, was passiert eigentlich?
Nix!
Sieht nur ungesund aus.
Ich sag doch Skyrim kann einfallen, Leute.
Oh, mehr Orks, aber wir versuchen immer Orks zu stellsen.
Oh, das sind zu viele Orks.
Leer, stehen bleiben.
Wir locken den jetzt an und jetzt, BÄÄM!
Alles klar.
ich meine
Komm mit mir!
Oh
Schaufel
Oh, ups
Ok, Lea möchte keine Schaufel gegen Spine haben
Lass die Schaufel hier
Ist hier irgendwas?
Ich will hier hoch
Ne, als ob du Dark Messiah spielst
Tja, siehste?
Mach ich
Das Game ist geil
Ich hab das schon vier, fünf Mal durchgespielt
Also vor Ewigkeiten
Max will zum Let's Play so
Also in letzter Zeit irgendwie schon
Aber es ist auch nicht was da los ist
Ring of Regeneration
Regeneration
Roppel
Zack
Don't forget that nice bow you found before
Oh, krasser Schwinger
Die ist schon scharf auf den Held
Noch mehr Orks
Ich bin mal gespannt, was ein Ork macht, wenn ich ihn anschieße von hier
Oh
Ja, was machst du jetzt Ork?
Was machst du jetzt?
Was machst du jetzt Ork?
Was machst du jetzt? Ich bin hier Ork
Und den hat's zerrissen
Direkt
So langsam läuft's
Haben wir hier noch Punkte für
Ne, zwei, zwei fehlen uns noch für Orkschwert
Ja, auf
Hi Simon, eins, zwei, vier, vier, zwei, eins, sechs
Beste
Machen wir
Vielleicht noch ein bisschen Hälfte, oder?
Oh
Das tut der schon weh
Demon Grill
Demon Grill, bestes Grill
So
Alter, ein Crypt-Sub
Was hier für Leute haben
Das müssen wir noch mal machen
Das müssen wir noch mal machen mit der Säule, die den Goblin erschlägt
What
Willst du mich rollen?
PTF
Warum ist er nicht gestorben davon?
Lull
Ich sag euch Weihnachten wird übelst geil
Ich wollte jetzt eigentlich sagen, warum
Ja, also ich mein nicht Weihnachten, Dezember wird übelst geil
Axt
Mir fehlt da so ein Schlüssel
Ähm, weil
Da hab ich den ganzen Monat bin ich da
Den ganzen Monat bin ich am Start
Der wird wahrscheinlich fast täglich gestriemt im Dezember
Wie kommt man da hin?
Muss man vielleicht doch das Zeug hier anschießen?
Ah
Oder was bringt mir das jetzt genau?
Ok, was, was, äh
Komm ich da jetzt irgendwie drauf?
Aha
Das ist jetzt ein Eis
Was gibt's denn hier?
Zeug weiß ich nicht brauche, aber trotzdem cool gefunden zu haben
Au
Ok, zurück muss ich auch nicht gehen
Ach, können wir noch ein Schwert forschen
Ah
Das kenn ich noch
Alter
Huu
Da konnte ich mich doch dran erinnern, sonst wäre ich jetzt hier direkt instant, instant vibe, instant verreckt
Wonka ist
Ah, irgendwie hab ich mich da grad wieder dran erinnert, dass ich das gleiche vor 10 Jahren schon mal hatte, in dem die Träner abgekratzt wurden
What?
What the fuck?
Was so, was war das?
What? Game, please
Ich würd sagen der Damage Träger ist an der Wand von dem Ding, ich muss warten bis das Rogue nicht mehr wackelt
Ok, jetzt warten wir
Aieieiei, mein Kuao, was? Kaulkappe
So, jetzt darf ich aber runter oder?
Ja
Gut, du hast ein Schild dabei aber
See you
Ja
Da haben wir doch das Richtige geskillt
Ne, jetzt nicht weiter
Das Orgschild, wie ist denn das Orgschild? 240? 80?
Das Orgschild sieht hässlich aus oder? Wir bleiben aber unsern hier
Ja, das ist besser
What's that?
Ja, was ist es? Ich mein wir wissen, dass ein Monster hier rumfliegt
Das wird's ja wohl sein
Oh oh
Ja ok, wie kill ich den jetzt?
Mit meinen krassen Bogenskills, hä?
Gute Idee Leia, gute Idee
Kommst du her?
Lass Leia in Ruhe, kommst du her?
Schreckt in your face
Da ist er down
Ich kann schon verstehen, dass sie den Held geil findet
Hi
Was ist das?
Keine Ahnung
Ja, wie gesagt, ich kann schon verstehen, dass die Schafe auf den Held sind
Ich kann schon verstehen, dass die Schafe auf den Held sind
Die Sounds, hörst du die Sounds an?